Oh, the Oscars last night, I watched it.
The whole thing.
Yep, you stay up late.
You watch the Oscars.
It is my favorite day of the year.
Even when I was a little kid, I love the Oscars.
And when my mom bought me out old,
like, red towel at the thrift store
and she would put it on our front porch
and on Oscars Sunday, I would always, like, stand on it
and she would take my picture
and the camera we had to wind it.
Do you remember?
I just love Oscar Sunday, the glamour, all of it.
I live for it.
Oh, well, you know, I love the history
of the Academy Awards
and the outfits, the films.
I think, looking back,
is what makes me love the Oscars today.
But we're following up that big glamorous night
with a big, beautiful story this morning,
POPSUGAR report that beauty products are going waterless.
What?
Okay, so check this out.
I know, because I said the same thing.
Brands are taking out the water
and giving you dry goods instead.
Shampoo bars, dry moisturizers, and body wash powder.
So this is, this is, okay.
I was like-
This is your shampoo
and this is your body wash,
which I have to say, like, I was a...
Oh, oh dear.
Yeah.
I was a big borax girl.
Like, remember, we used to put your hands in the thing
and do the, does everybody remember that?
And I miss that.
I love scrubbing with the granules.
So I'm feeling this.
Yeah, the little grits?
At first I was like, H2-OMG,
I dunno know how I feel about this.
Like what are you talking about?
But, it's actually good.
If you're traveling, imagine you're camping or something.
I don't know.
Maybe it's a stretch.
I just kinda like soap.
Is that too much to ask for?
You know what though, for traveling,
'cause you can't travel.
It's open.
So every time you make a point, you're like...
(laughing)
I'm like, when you travel,
it's great because you can't bring water.
By the way, this company also has nipple and areola stick.
What's, what do you do with that?
I didn't realize that that was a thing.
(laughing)
It's like chapstick for your ni...
All right, well, next we've got news from Vogue
about a beautiful new jewelry collaboration.
You're gonna love this.
Fashion brand Private Policy
and artist Chella Man
have teamed up to create a special line of ear jewelry
to celebrate the deaf and the hard of hearing communities.
Chella has dealt with hearing devices since childhood
and his designs are meant to accentuate
and honor the hearing aids and hearing implants.
And this was launched for National Deaf History Month.
And get this, 50% of profits
go to the Deaf Queer Resource Center.
(audience applauding)
Yes.
And they're so beautiful, right?
I think they are absolute works of art.
It's artistic.
It has depth and meaning.
It's celebrating something.
It's philanthropic.
Just, I love it.
I love it too.
And when I see somebody wearing one of those,
like, with your hair up
and you sort of turn
and you have that moment, it's stunning.
So if you've never worn one, give it a shot.
Well, finally, you know, we love to turn to TikTok
to solve life's little problems.
And, today, we've got an incredible TikTok hack
that's supposed to solve an age-old problem.
We've all been there.
How do you chop an onion without crying like a maniac?
Drew, have you been in the kitchen,
just having a moment with your tears?
I heard, like, chewing gum helps
but I've never had gum around
because I don't like chewing gum.
I hear lighting a candle or a match helps,
but, Tiktok said-
For how long?
You gonna do light the match over and over and over again?
I don't know.
I'm not a scientist, Drew.
That's why I turned to TikTok.
They say-
(laughing)
They say, well, the secret is,
it wants to go to moisture, right?
So if you lay a damp paper towel
next to your cutting board,
it absorbs the chemical in the onion that makes you cry
before it hits your peepers.
That's what they say.
And so we have here a wet paper towel and some onions.
So do you wanna chop it-
Oh, it is wet.
Thank you, Daniel.
It is wet.
Yeah, so I don't know if this is gonna work,
but this is, this would change my life if it did,
because I hate that when I tear up.
I do, I feel like I'm about to lose a finger.
Don't you dare.
I know it's not stable.
I'm just telling you.
I have to say my face is right here in it
and I'm not crying at all.
I mean, hold on.
Let me take off my glasses.
Look, nothing, no tears.
Nothing.
Yeah, I have to say, like, I mean,
maybe it's the nipple balm
but something is working over here.
(laughing)
Maybe it's the wet paper towel.
I have to say,
I think this is really working.
Yeah, because I'm seriously not getting any tears.
I'm getting a tiny whiff in my peepers, but,
nothing compared to what I usually feel like,
which is like,
(Drew bawling)
you know?
So are you gonna try this next time you're cooking?
Are you gonna, literally, do it?
I have to say, I'm totally gonna do it.
This is a game changer
(chopping sound)
I think I am too.
I mean, nothing.
That's amazing.
(upbeat music)